rain just listen to the cold steel ring
lord lord just piss into the coast
in 1960 harry belafonte became the first
african american to ever win an emmy for
his variety special tonight with
belafonte
i think we should use our platform in
which to help to influence people
and enlighten people about who we are
and what we are about and what we can
achieve
and let them feel inspired by that i
remember the last bake sale
we lost 50 and gained 11 pounds
moving on up to 1981 isabelle sanford's
iconic role in the jeffersons
won her the emmy for outstanding actress
in a comedy
making her the first african-american
woman to win in the category
it was a joy and a shock listen doc i
need my dosage
i've given five years eighty thousand
dollars in my freedom
for this i'm finding who i'm supposed to
be fast forward to 2014
laverne cox's performance in the popular
netflix series orange is the new black
made her the first transgender person to
ever be nominated for an emmy
i hope that it inspires a lot of other
trans actors to pursue their dreams and
know that their dreams are possible
the following year viola davis made
history as the first woman of color to
win in the best actress in a drama
series category
for her role in how to get away with
murder you know we put our work out
there as women of color constantly for
so many years
and it's our time jumping in time to
2017
donald glover took home an emmy for best
director in a comedy series for his hit
show atlanta
we were just saying this the other day
the win made history by making donald
the first african american
to win an emmy in that category i always
wanted to just make good things
like that's all that's important to me
i'm like quality is for the people
i try we we always talk about in
atlanta's writers room just make
something quality
and hopefully people so i i never yeah
never thought about in those terms i
just want to make something good
that same year lena wade became the
first african-american woman to win an
emmy for comedy writing for masters of
nuns thanksgiving episode
do you understand the history you made
tonight you know what i do
i do i think i'm very aware of how
important this win was
because it's not just about me it's
about all these amazing women of color
who are phenomenal writers
two lead actors also made history that
year
sterling kate brown won the emmy for
outstanding lead actor in the drama
series for his role as randall pearson
on this is us
who the hell is my name is randall i'm
your biological son
making him the first african-american to
earn the award in that category in
nearly 20 years
this is historical it's been 19 years
since a brother brought
home this particular piece of hardware
andre brown andre brower in 1998
and so to be the next
one i i i'm almost
at a loss for words and when riz ahmed
won an emmy for his lead role in the
limited series the night of
he became the first actor of asian
descent to win an acting category
ever yes in 2017.
have you digested what happened what
just happened it's
it's just digesting slowly now yeah it's
quite a crazy thing
and the very next year in 2018 sandra
o's performance in killing eve earned
her an emmy nod for lead actress in a
drama series
that's yeah
[Applause]
he can't i can
it made her the first woman of asian
descent to be nominated in the category
it may come it may not but the thing
just being here is
i will say is the thing the win did not
come that year for sandra but
while we are talking about making
history at the emmys we have to talk
about
julia louis-dreyfus what do you think
you are gary antoinette
did somebody make you first lady because
i don't remember marrying you gary
julia took home six emmy awards for her
performance as president selena meyer
in veep the most awards anyone has ever
won for a single role
you said i was gonna jinx you by saying
you're gonna win six in a row and now
look yeah cause i knocked on wood
didn't you is that what's saying so
you're knocked on wood or you didn't
you tried to screw me